j'accueille roxane mesquida
roczen bonsoir bon ça vous appelez
roxane à cause de la chanson donc c'est
ça non adoré cette chanson vous la jouer
à peu près on vous lâche entrepris 14
fois par jours j'imagine oui voilà donc
je suis très original désaccord pas un
gros points ce soir
vous ressemblez à romy schneider vous
êtes fallait romy schneider
ouais j'aime beaucoup c'est une actrice
formidable
ouais les 19 ans montpellier après avoir
habité à toulon et vous jouez
c'est votre troisième film vous jouer
dans le film de catherine breillat qui
vient de sortir qui s'appelle à ma soeur
vous avez déjà donc jeudi 12 août film
marie baie des anges de manuel pradal en
vous avez repéré sur une piste cyclable
que vous avez de la chance vous marchez
thérapie ces cycles a tranquillement
avec ma maman et puis manuel pradal d'un
repérée elle m'a demandé de passer des
essais voilà la prise et là vous oublier
complètement votre votre ambition de
devenir prof d'anglais
oui il a vite laissé tomber le
professeur
je suis très bien ensemble et maintenant
ouais et un jour votre mère voit une
annonce dans un journal
pour l'école de la chair de benoît
jacquot deuxième film we
et ensuite votre mère voit encore une
annonce dans un journal pour le film de
bryan sa mère oui elle vous pousse votre
mère être partout non c'est elle c'est
que j'ai envie de faire ça donc elle me
donne les possibilités en fait donc elle
me payer tous les voyages pour elle à
paris et donc faisait toutes les petites
annonces et des magazines corriger le
scénario du film de catherine breillat
vous êtes encore au lycée
vous lisez pendant une heure de temps
libre vous êtes troublé en fait je peux
pas définir j'étais je suis pas comme un
zombie en fait ouais
j'étais trop bizarre et c'est un peu
comme si le monde qui m'entoure et
n'existait plus et ça m'a vraiment
bouleversée comme histoire le début
romance ouais je les ai vus après en
fait après vous avez entendu parler
oui marie ça vous n'êtes pas peur de
faire un film avec catherine breillat
après le commencement
non j'ai pas peur au contraire ça m'a
donné envie de le faire ah bon vous pas
peur de rocco siffredi et vous non c'est
d'ailleurs catherine on l'a présenté il
est vachement sympa si l'on choisit les
couples se forment
on fait
alors le pitch du film de catherine
breillat c'est anaïs qui s'appelle en
fait dans la vie anaïs aussi un mail au
bout elena c'est vous êtes en vacances
avec votre famille dans les landes les
deux soeurs vous êtes belle et votre
soeur est belle mais un peu enveloppé du
ça pourrait être sympa tu vois plusieurs
grosses mais aller et vous faites des
puces et la première et oui c'est assez
hard quand même non non non maintenant
quand je dis c'était mon meilleur jour
de tournage le dépucelage plan séquence
et huit minutes où je suis nue
et je m'en vais débuter oui c'est à dire
que allait dépêcher puisque vous en
parlez jan aps avait débuté de trois
façons annales d'abord le garçon lui
explique que ça compte pas ensuite aura
leçons n'en parle même pas imagine alors
là c'est le moment où vous donnez
vraiment c'est la preuve d'amour ça voit
s'approcher un petit peu
dès qu'on parle de sexe très intéressant
donc j'ai des puces les de ces trois
façons la par le dénommé fernando dans
le film qui en fait libero de rienzo ces
noms d'acteurs qui vous en bobines en
fait votre soeur évidemment elle est
allée un peu jaloux vous avez un peu
frustré elle veut perdre sa virginité
avec n'importe qui avec un homme qu'elle
n'aime pas et son rêve sera exaucé d'une
manière assez cruel à la fin du film la
fa tsy un quart d'heure qui est
insoutenable à la fin du film
vous êtes vous êtes fâché avec l'acteur
va libero de rienzo là non on pouvait
pas soir ah bon c'est vrai ouais c'est
vrai ça devait être sympa le tournage
pour ça que vous avez tourné le dos
ce n'est pas moi non pouvait pas se voir
mais je sais pas pourquoi
ouais je suis né mais pas trop quoi vous
étiez pas audio non mais quand un acteur
on laisse couler un filet de bave sur
son menton avant de l'embrasser ça donne
pas du tout envie quoi
c'est un syndic ce chat libero de rienzo
beaux-parents vu le film ma maman j'ai
pas de papa ouais mais qu'est ce qu'elle
a dit votre moment est très fière de moi
bien
elle regrette pas d'avoir répondu la
petite annonce au nom contraire bien
vous échappez rocco siffredi y aurait-il
le film d'avant soit était peut-être
plus dur c'est vrai que je suis là
cette fois au bout de vos peines
interview première fois c'est le cas de
le dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
interview première fois premier souvenir
quand je me suis noyée
vous êtes noyer et quand j'ai toujours
non à bandol je m'inscris dans une
piscine et ma mère m'a repêché de
justesse quand j'avais deux ans ah oui
et en fait c'est bizarre parce que j'ai
le souvenir des carreaux bleu quand je
coulais c'était agréable ne s'était pas
désagréable premier mensonge je sais pas
mentir premier péché je vois pas qu'est
ce qui est un péché première baffe
jamais jamais si une fois dans un film
c'était dans la vraie vie non non ah si
une fois un type 1 type que je
connaissais pas non parce qu'en fait moi
je parle beaucoup et j'aime bien voyez
des petites vannes assez méchante et un
jour quelqu'un l'a très mal pris et je
me suis pris une baffe premier coup de
foudre
mon amour est ce qu'ils faisaient à zain
c'est moi qui n'ai pas à un bon d'accord
premier baiser sur la bouche sans la
langue je suis pas non ça n'est pas non
en fait c'est épuisant
voilà ouais annoncée très tard et est
traité avec les décalages trop tard non
je ne dirais pas c'est la honte
genre 12 13 ans non 16
ouais première fois toute nue avec un
garçon boucher pareil oui c'est tout en
même temps c'était le jour où il fallait
être là quoi première fois à troyes
jamais jamais encore pas même pas encore
n'ont jamais ça vous pouvez pas vous
intéresse pas ça m'intéresse pas du tout
du tout du tout du tout à la fois 4 donc
ces imbéciles de où le vent des 60
premiers chagrins d'amour dit c'est trop
mais en fait non parce que non j'ai pas
non en fait c'est bête mais je regrette
d'avoir eu un chagrin d'amour pour lui
ouais il méritait pas un chagrin d'amour
voilà la première scène de ménage avec
sud et la times
je crois jamais jamais encore siwel un
mauvais caractère
ah bon ouais je m'énerve je claque la
porte et tout ça dure pas longtemps
alors ça dure pas longtemps
non je n'arrive pas dans les pas du tout
et n'en restera chez avec chérif bah
ouais c'est ça vous fait la tête vous
fait du mal donc vous retourne à qui
revient le premier c'est vous c'est lui
noir l'a fait attention pas être soumise
comme sa première il résiste pas pardon
il résiste pas mon cas je comprends un
peu abrupte en première cuite bat pas
encore en fait je suis spécial coup je
ne bois pas d'alcool mais ce qui me
saoule c'est le coca coca ça saoule
qu'est ce que le regard rien n'annonce
un non mais c'est vrai ah bon oui je dit
que des conneries à tréguier pas
d'alcool 0 tc ou pas c'était mal
chacun son trio lola déjà quelques idées
nasa les premiers pétards
ben en fait je suis même pas de pétards
mais je fume passivement parce que je
suis fan de concert de régner donc
d'accord si votre façon vous dépensez
vous avez des conserveries christian
suffit première cigarette autorisée sept
ans c'est en web et votre mère vous
laisser fumer réseau s'est elle m'a fait
essayer j'ai trouvé ça tellement
dégueulasse que je n'ai plus jamais
chemin et jeunes filles ou pas ben
prochain film c'est quoi ces radars et
aux prochaines fois non non le prochain
tim âge en effet un autre après qui
s'appelle sec stress d'opposer d'eric
assous sinon non voyons non mais j'ai
pas un rôle très important dans mon
prochain film c'est à voir
je ne sais pas encore votre mère du
journal là pour gagner petites annonces
non j'ai un agent maintenant quand même
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus